[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ضجه كبيره بدات مع بدء عرض مسلسل
الفلوجه في تونس ومطالبات بايقاف العمل
ابرزها كانت من وزاره التربيه بمصالح
القانونيه واللي رفعت دعوه تطالب بمراجعه
العمل وحذف مشاهد اعتبرتها مسيئه للمؤسسات
العموميه وللمربين والتلاميذ على حد
السواء كل صدق مكملتوش ما كملتوش على خاطر
انا حسيتو المسلسل هذايا ماهوش
مع كل من
طالب بدعوه الى ايقاف هذا لانه يسيء منه
ويسيء من شبيبتنا ومن تلاميذه النوبه
المؤسسه التربويه خاصه هو المسلسل فيه
القى متاع التونسي راه وفي زاده قلت
احترام على خاطر عبيد في رمضان تجيب حاجات
محترمه وعبده تجيب حاجه تعقل التربيه
اي مسلسل اي فيلم يتعدى على هيئه
ممثلين ما شاء الله عليهم اوكي موضوع حساس
هو صحيح اللي يحكيو فيه مانع وكل
صاير في تونس بالعكس انا
وتعيش فيه في الحقيقه كامل درامي يوصل
الواقع
وصل المخبي
ة أنا عايشينه
في المدارس على غرار ترويج المخدرات
والعلاقات العاطفيه والعنف ودور رجال
الامن فيما يحصل في محيط المدارس وعلاقه
المراهقين باوليائهم مواضيع اعتبرها البعض
ليست جريئه بل المدعيه
هذا محمد المسؤوليه للشباب هما بيدهم حمله
المسؤوليه للعائلات المسؤوليه زاده
المؤسسه التربويه مشيت في جماليه جماليه
اللي جملت الواقع بالحق جملته علي موجود
خاطر اللي موجود
اقصى واصعب وامر وخايب اكثر من ويفجع اكثر
التواصل الاجتماعي امتلات بردود الفعل ما
بين من يعتبر المحتوى خارج عن المالوف
ويضرب بمظوميه الاخلاق للمجتمع وما بين
مؤيد يراه انتاج قريب من الواقع ويعكس
الصور الحقيقيه للمجتمع دون تزييف ولا
يشكل اي خطر على الشباب الناشئ
[موسيقى]
ون
انا قررت